LIAR, ADAM SCHIFF?
THAT WOULD BE HARD TO BELIEVE.
JOINING US NOW WITH REACTION,
SOUTH CAROLINA
SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM.
SENATOR, WITH ALL DUE RESPECT,
YOU RIGHTLY SAID IF THERE IS NO
DUE PROCESS, IT'S DEAD ON
ARRIVAL IN THE SUN IT I WOULD
THINK THE SENATE, LED BY
REPUBLICANS, IS NOT GOING TO PUT
REPUBLICANS, IS NOT GOING TO PUA
REPUBLICANS, IS NOT GOING TO PUS
REPUBLICANS, IS NOT GOING TO PUL
REPUBLICANS, IS NOT GOING TO PUO
REPUBLICANS, IS NOT GOING TO PUF
REPUBLICANS, IS NOT GOING TO PUA
REPUBLICANS, IS NOT GOING TO PUP
REPUBLICANS, IS NOT GOING TO PUO
REPUBLICANS, IS NOT GOING TO PUA
REPUBLICANS, IS NOT GOING TO PUL
REPUBLICANS, IS NOT GOING TO PUO
REPUBLICANS, IS NOT GOING TO PUN
SOMETHING AS CORRUPT AS THIS.
>> I WOULD THINK IT WOULD BE A
DANGER TO THE PRESIDENCY AND THE
FUTURE FOR US IF WE LEGITIMIZE
WHAT IS GOING ON IN THE HOUSE.
THERE'S NO CIVIL PROCEEDING IN
AMERICA, NO CRIMINAL PROCEEDING
IN AMERICA, THAT DENIES THE
PERSON TO TELL THEIR SIDE OF THE
STORY BY CALLING WITNESSES,
EXCEPT IN THE HOUSE.
AND EVERY AMERICAN DESERVES THE
RIGHT TO CONFRONT THEIR ACCUSER.
THAT'S NOT BEING DONE IN THIS
CASE.
I DON'T WANT TO LEGITIMIZE THIS
BECAUSE IT'S A STRETCHED TO THE
PRESIDENCY.
THEN THERE'S THE ALLEGATION THAT
DONALD J. TRUMP WITHHELD AID TO
THE UKRAINE, UNLESS THE
UKRAINIAN GOVERNMENT
INVESTIGATOR JOE BIDEN AND
HUNTER BIDEN FOR CORRUPTION.
THE PROBLEM WITH THAT ALLEGATION
IS IT'S NOT TRUE.
THE AIDE WAS DELIVERED TO THE
UKRAINIAN GOVERNMENT, AND THERE
WAS NO INVESTIGATION OF HUNTER
BIDEN OR JOE BIDEN.
HOW LONG DOES IT TAKE TO DISPOSE
OF THAT?
>> Sean: LET ME ASK YOU,
BECAUSE AGAIN, THE DUE
PROCESS -- YOU WERE PART OF
IMPEACHMENT IN 1998.
THIS IS NOT YOUR FIRST RODEO,
SENATOR.
YOU ARE EATING YOURSELF.
I WAS ON THE AIR, TOO
OKAY, GUILTY.
EVERY CONSIDERATION THAT WAS
GIVEN BILL CLINTON, BILL
CLINTON'S LAWYERS, THE MINORITY
PARTY, ARE ALL DENIED HERE
BECAUSE OF THE END OF THE
PARAGRAPH IT SAYS THE SAME
THING, IT GOES, AT THE
DISCRETION OF THE CHAIRMAN.
HE SAID HE WANTED THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER.
REPUBLICANS GAVE A LIST -- THEY
SAID NO TO EVERY REPUBLICAN
WITNESSES, AND A CHERRY PICKING
THE TWO WITNESSES THEY THINK
WILL BE MOST FAVORABLE TO THEM
AND NOT THE ONES THAT WOULD
DESTROY THEIR NARRATIVE.
WHAT COMMITTEE IN THE SENATE
COULD CALL WITNESSES AND
INVESTIGATE HUNTER AND JOE,
BECAUSE I IDENTIFIED THE LAWS I
BELIEVE JOE BIDEN BROKE.
>> THE ALLEGATION AGAINST HUNTER
BIDEN IS THAT HE HAD A CONFLICT
OF INTEREST BY SERVING ON THE
BOARD, AND THAT JOE BIDEN
WAITING TO HAVE THE PROSECUTOR
FIRED BECAUSE HE WAS
GETTING CLOSE TO HIS SON.
THE STATE DEPARTMENT TALKED
ABOUT THE CONFLICT OF INTEREST,
AND THERE IS A REASONABLE
INVESTIGATION TO BE DONE HERE.
THE FOREIGN RELATIONS COMMITTEE
HAS JURISDICTION OVER THE
STATE DEPARTMENT.
BUT LET ME GET BACK TO THE POINT
YOU JUST MADE.
WHAT'S HAPPENING IN THE HOUSE IS
BASICALLY UNAMERICAN.
NO AMERICAN, INCLUDING
DONALD TRUMP, SHOULD BE ACCUSED
OF MISDEEDS WITHOUT CONFRONTING
THEIR ACCUSER, WHICH IS THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER, AND NO AMERICAN
SHOULD BE DENIED THE ABILITY TO
TELL THEIR SIDE OF THE STORY BY
CALLING WITNESSES TO EXPLAIN
THEIR DEFENSE.
THAT'S BEING DENIED THE
PRESIDENT OF UNITED STATES.
TO EVERY AMERICAN WHO IS GOING
TO WATCH TOMORROW, THIS CANNOT
HAPPEN IN YOUR CASE.
THIS COULDN'T HAPPEN IN A
PARKING TICKET CASE.
THIS COULDN'T HAPPEN IN ANY
CIVIL MATTER IN AMERICA, BECAUSE
DUE PROCESS REQUIRES THE ABILITY
OF EVERY AMERICAN TO CALL
WITNESSES ON THEIR BEHALF --
EXCEPT FOR PRESIDENT TRUMP.
SO WHY AM I NOT GOING TO WATCH
THIS HEARING TOMORROW?
BECAUSE I THINK IT IS A THREAT
TO THE PRESIDENCY.
I DON'T WANT TO LEGITIMIZE IT.
ITS UNAMERICAN.
AMERICAN QUICKLY DENIES THE
BASICS OF DUE PROCESS.
>> Sean: WHY WON'T THE SENATE
NOW, THEY HAVE THE ABILITY TO
INVESTIGATE.
LISTEN, JOE BIDEN IS BRAGGING ON
TAPE ABOUT GIVING -- YOU EITHER
FIRE THIS PROSECUTOR IN SIX
HOURS.
IF YOU FIRE HIM, I WILL GIVE YOU
A BILLION TAXPAYER DOLLARS.
IF YOU DON'T FIRE THE PROSECUTOR
THAT'S INVESTIGATING MY ZERO
EXPERIENCE SON, WHO IS BEING
PAID MILLIONS, I'M TAKING THE
MONEY BACK WITH ME.
NOW THAT, TO MEAN, LOOKS LIKE A
CRIME.
SO WHY ISN'T THE SENATE, NOW
THAT WE KNOW THAT ALL HAPPENED,
INVESTIGATING -- FOR EXAMPLE,
WHO WOULD YOU LIKE TO BE CALLED
IN AS WITNESSES, IN WHAT
COMMITTEE IN THE SENATE COULD CL
COMMITTEE IN THE SENATE COULD CT
COMMITTEE IN THE SENATE COULD CE
COMMITTEE IN THE SENATE COULD CM
COMMITTEE IN THE SENATE COULD CI
COMMITTEE IN THE SENATE COULD C?
>> THE FOREIGN RELATIONS
COMMITTEE HAS JURISDICTION OVER
FOREIGN AID.
THE STATE DEPARTMENT.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT JOE BIDEN
SAID YOU ARE NOT GOING TO GET A
PENNY UNLESS YOU FIRE THE
PROSECUTOR.
HERE'S THE QUESTION: AFTER JOHN
SOLOMON'S FOIA REQUEST, IS THERE
REASON TO BELIEVE THAT JOE BIDEN
INTERVENED, NOT BECAUSE THE
PROSECUTOR WAS CORRUPT, BUT
BECAUSE HE WAS GETTING CLOSE TO
HIS SON?
THE PAPER TRAIL SUGGEST THERE IS
A REASONABLE BELIEF, OR AT LEAST
SOMETHING TO LOOK AT HERE.
SO I'M HOPING THAT CHAIRMAN
RIDGE WILL LOOK INTO WHETHER ORN
RIDGE WILL LOOK INTO WHETHER ORT
RIDGE WILL LOOK INTO WHETHER ORE
RIDGE WILL LOOK INTO WHETHER ORW
RIDGE WILL LOOK INTO WHETHER ORS
RIDGE WILL LOOK INTO WHETHER ORA
RIDGE WILL LOOK INTO WHETHER ORC
RIDGE WILL LOOK INTO WHETHER ORN
RIDGE WILL LOOK INTO WHETHER ORL
RIDGE WILL LOOK INTO WHETHER ORC
RIDGE WILL LOOK INTO WHETHER ORT
RIDGE WILL LOOK INTO WHETHER ORO
RIDGE WILL LOOK INTO WHETHER ORF
INTEREST IDENTIFIED BY THE
STATE DEPARTMENT REGARDING
HUNTER BIDEN BEING ON THIS GAS
BOARD, AND WHETHER OR NOT
JOE BIDEN INTERVENED AFTER THAT.
>> Sean: CAN THE SENATE CALL
IN THE HEARSAY WHISTLE-BLOWER
AND PUT THAT PERSON UNDER OATH,
SHOULD THE SENATE ALSO CALL IN
ADAM SCHIFF, ADAM SCHIFF STAFF,
WHATEVER CONTACT THEY HAD, AND
SHOULD THEY CALL IN JOE AND
HUNTER BIDEN?
AND WHY IS THIS HAPPENING
SIMULTANEOUSLY,'S THE PEOPLE CAN
SEE BOTH SIDES OF THIS COME AND
SEE WHERE THE REAL CORRUPTION
LIES?
>> THE WHISTLE-BLOWERS UNDER THE
JURISDICTION OF THE INTEL
COMMITTEE.
ALL THINGS ABOUT HUNTER BIDEN OR
IN THE JURISDICTION OF THE
FOREIGN RELATIONS COMMITTEE.
IF I WERE CHAIRMAN RIDGE, I
WOULD CALL THE STATE DEPARTMENT
OFFICIALS IN, WHO EXPRESSED
CONCERNS ABOUT A CONFLICT OF
INTEREST WITH HUNTER BIDEN, AND
SEE WHERE THAT TAKES YOU.
>> Sean: CAN YOU MAYBE TALK TO
YOUR COLLEAGUES IN THE SENATE
AND MAKE THAT HAPPEN?
>> WELL, THE FIRST THINGS I WANT
MY COLLEAGUES TO DO IS STEP UP
AND SAY WHAT IS GOING ON IN THE
HOUSE IS UNFAIR, UNAMERICAN
COMEDY WERE KNUCKLING TO BLESS
IT.
I WOULD LIKE MY COLLEAGUES IN
THE SENATE TO SAY THERE WAS NO
QUID PRO QUO BECAUSE THE AIDE
WAS GIVEN.
I WOULD LIKE REPUBLICANS TO STEP
UP AND SAY THIS IS A BUNCH OF
GARBAGE.
>> Sean: BY THE WAY, THE
PRESIDENT HAS A DUTY TO
FAITHFULLY EXECUTE THE LAWS ON
BOTH ISSUES.
THERE WERE LAWS THAT WERE BROKEN
AND THEY NEVER MENTIONED ANY AID
MONEY, DID THEY?
>> NOT 1 PENNY.